hey what's up person are you frustrated
with your life no are you uh tired of
spinning your wheels and you keep on
watching self-improvement videos trying
to find that aha moment the thing that
gets you out of your rut if that's you
stop that well Jake it's a relief to
know what's been eaten on you I I wish
you'd have told me sooner getting to
where you want to be in life it's
difficult absolutely but it's extremely
simple the method to getting anything
that you could possibly want in life
comes down to I would argue three things
if you can get all these three things
right then there's nothing that can stop
you unless you know all of your limbs
get blown off in a terrible
accident number one you need to develop
a vision because without a vision there
will be absolutely no telling whether
you're making progress in Life or not
most people do not have an adequate
vision for where they want to be most
people wake up every single day and just
look at the tasks they have at hand and
just sort of vaguely hope that they will
make more money find a girlfriend get a
nice house eventually they have all of
these sort of pre-installed vague NPC
sentiments in their head things that
would be nice right but of course you
want those things everybody wants those
things those things are not a vision
that's just sort of like accidentally
inheriting the sentiments of society you
need to develop a vision that is
exciting to you and your life a vision
that I can't tell you about I can't tell
you what's exciting to you but you have
to figure it out you must figure it out
so ask yourself you know if everything
went your way and you behaved optimally
if you managed to find the discipline
necessary to overcome the little
obstacles in your life and the big ones
where would you ideally want to be one
year from now take out a pen and paper
and write these things down in detail
you have to create Crea a vision that
excites you otherwise you will distract
yourself with pleasure so when you're
constructing this Vision I highly
encourage you to not just think about
the things you want to have everybody
wants to wake up in a nice giant
household with a big comfy bed and drive
off in their Lambo have a very
fulfilling job that makes them a lot of
money and they have all these nice
clothes and their body is nice and
jacked and these things are nice to
think about but a far more important
question is how do you want to behave
what kind of person do you want to be
how do you want it to feel to be you you
can imagine yourself with all these
luxuries around you but at the end of
the day think about what that would feel
like to be you is it sort of powerful
peaceful focused do you want to be
somebody who has their priorities in
line somebody who has sort of burned
away their lesser self are you somebody
who wakes up in the morning with energy
just teeming with motivation and
excitement to tackle the most important
things in your day develop a vision
that's more exciting to you than the
pleasures that surround you okay so the
next thing is to weaponize your
attention almost everybody
underestimates the power of their
attention but there are very few people
in the world who understand it fully and
those people are in power the people who
understand attention fully those are the
people who've created an entire economy
around human attention look no further
than your Tech Giants of the world the
truth is human attention is the most
valuable resource on the planet when
people focus on something when a society
focuses on something things get done or
undone societies are built or they
crumble and the modern landscape is
built very evidently around influencing
maintaining and controlling human
attention even me right now talking in
front of this camera the longer you pay
attention the better this video will do
for me but hopefully I can leave you
with something where you can go oh wait
I need to develop my own Vision I need
to pay attention to that vision and I
need to make things happen in my own
life and then hopefully you don't need
to watch my sh you don't need to watch
anybody's you can be paying
attention to what you want to be paying
attention to so in order to gain
Traction in your life you need to
realize that your attention is the
vehicle that will drive you towards your
North Star and it makes perfect sense
because attention is a prediction where
our eyes gaze our feet tend to follow
you know a really good example of this
is how I became a YouTuber how did I get
here is this exactly what I've always
wanted to do with my life not really I
still want to be a director and create
high quality art be a master of Cinema
but it makes perfect sense why I ended
up here for the time being and that's
because that is all I paid attention to
as a kid I was constantly making YouTube
videos with my friends comedy sketch es
fight scenes I was constantly absorbing
and uploading to YouTube it's where my
attention was and soon my feet followed
so ask yourself are you treating your
attention with respect and in what ways
are you allowing your attention to go
elsewhere what are you obsessed with
what's constantly on your mind whatever
that is if it's not towards your vision
you will lack the fuel to get there so
this might all sound extremely overly
simple but I think the TR EST things in
life are generally pretty
straightforward it's just it doesn't
mean that it's easy in fact honing your
attention on what matters is very
difficult but the final component of all
this will help you achieve it it'll make
things easier for you and I've found it
personally very helpful as of late a lot
of the ideas from this video were
inspired by outwitting the Devil by
Napoleon Hill I listened to that
recently using today's video sponsor
Audible and I think that you should too
because because this is the first
audiobook that I recommended on the
Channel that I didn't completely love
and why does that mean you should listen
to it well I think it's because the good
points that Napoleon Hill makes are
really good they're sort of Life
perspective altering points and that's
why I made this video however there are
some other Concepts from the Audi book
that I'm a little bit lukewarm about and
sometimes they come across as crazy or
just genuinely unhinged and I want you
to experience that for yourself and and
for those of you who don't know audible
is the leading provider of audio
entertainment and audiobooks all in one
place every single month they send you
one credit which you can spend on any
audiobook of your choice regardless of
cost and you get to keep that audiobook
forever audible members also get instant
access to a rapidly expanding catalog of
audible Originals podcasts and exclusive
Series so if you're interested in
joining me in being big brained and
listening to some of the greatest
insights ever recorded then if you use
my link in the description below or text
better ideas to 500500 then you'll get a
30-day free trial once again go to
audible.com better ideas or just text
better ideas to 500500 to get your
30-day free trial and thanks again to
Audible for sponsoring this video so
this final component is surrender I'll
call it surrender for this video but
last video I called it submission so
let's rewind a little bit remember how
at the beginning I talked about
reflecting on who who you want to be and
what you want it to feel like to be you
well chances are when you were imagining
that when you were really thinking about
that you actually felt it right you
actually caught a glimpse and were able
to relax into that feeling your posture
probably changed a little bit maybe you
were very stressed before you're very
uptight about all these things you have
to do but you allowed yourself for just
a few minutes to relax into the
possibility
of feeling different well that is proof
that you can feel that way right now the
feeling that you want to feel is
available to you at all times right you
can be right now the person that you
want to be therefore all of these
external circumstances that you want for
your life are merely the branches that
grow out from this authentic feeling of
being you and that probably sounds very
wo wo woo but just give it a thought
okay maybe it's not so much that getting
what you want in life externally will
make you feel who you want to feel like
but rather feeling how you want to feel
in life and behaving in the way that you
wish to behave and being the person that
you want to be will help you get all of
these things as a byproduct so as I was
editing this video I realized that I
just straight up didn't explain what
submission even is I just started
talking talking about something entirely
different I already talked about this in
like two other
videos um but yeah I should really stop
overusing this concept I think I should
really write some new material
submission is basically this idea
instead of you know like when you need
to do something that you know you need
to do there's all this like
physiological tension right you feel
very like if I could just get myself to
do it right then I'd be a better person
but I suck right there's a lot of
there's a lot of tension right we kind
of fight ourselves but when you have a
vision for what you want to feel like
who you want to be and you allow
yourself to feel it then submission is
almost like this this Act of Faith it's
less even psychological it's more
physiological you you just do the thing
anyways and I know that sounds very
reductionistic but doing anything in
life is just doing the thing anyways you
can you can try to hyper cerebral doing
doing what you need to do and over
complicated it but at the end of the day
it's just a matter of doing it or not
doing it so I found personally that it's
actually easier to do what's good for
you if you relax into it physically and
psychologically this this act of just
putting one foot in front of the other
and having faith that this is the right
thing for you so it's like
counterintuitive you almost try less
hard to do what's right for you but as
you get better at doing this you just
kind of disregard the uh resistance in
your way you start to become very
familiar with the feelings that are on
the other side of this Wall of
Resistance it's a feeling of Peace of
calm of Duty sometimes it's even a
feeling of excitement you you get very
excited that you're actually finally
doing what you need to do right it's a
it's a very good feeling and a lot of
the time when we procrastinate and we're
doing all these you know we're we're
doom scrolling Instagram or whatever we
are actually looking for this feeling
and we just can't find it at Instagram
we can't find it on Tik Tok it's only
found by relaxing into what you know you
need to be doing relaxing in to the
steps necessary to achieve your vision
and there's no better feeling than that
some call it a flow State um You can
call it whatever you want but it's the
best feeling in the world so get good at
submitting to your higher conception of
good um You can call it your your
heavenly Duty your vision of heaven and
good luck just do it but enjoy yourself
as you do it if you liked this video
make sure that you actually hit like
because when you hit the like button the
algorithm blesses me YouTube the
algorithm goes okay this video is cool
more people should watch this that
really helps me out and it helps
everybody out so it's just a win-win if
you're lurking here consider subscribing
other than that though thank you so much
for watching and we'll catch you in the
next video